a una región a la que no es fácil entrar
en un país ya con una geografía muy
accidentada los vestigios de este
contingente soviético dan fe de la
dificultad para acceder a bank here es
el corazón histórico de la resistencia
antitalibán en afganistán es la única de
las 34 provincias del país que no ha
caído en manos de los insurgentes
situada al noroeste de kabul es conocida
porque su entrada principal es un
estrecho cañón algo que le da una
situación privilegiada para atacar desde
lo alto a cualquier invasor la entrada a
panshir por el sur es el túnel de salang
que fue dinamitado en 1997 y ahora
funciona de manera intermitente este
ataque contra el túnel lo hizo ahmad zia
masud el conocido como el león del
panshir el que fuera el líder de la
resistencia antitalibán fue asesinado en
2001 por el grupo terrorista al qaeda en
ese entonces liderado por osama bin
laden ahora es el hijo de ahmad ahmad
masood quien lidera la actual
resistencia y aún desde panshir la
región además alberga una gran parte de
los tayikos el segundo grupo étnico más
importante de afganistán que compone una
cuarta de su población